là monsieur bonsoir je voudrais regarder
la france au fond des yeux l'une
j'aimerais beaucoup que je m'apprête à
tricoter à votre place je la ramène un
peu moins mais si vous ne réussissez pas
ce qu'il vous manque qu'une seule chose
un tout petit détail le pari de ce qui
lui arrive à la baule comme chaque
semaine france info et l'ina vous offre
un voyage dans le temps à travers les
archives de la télévision pour mieux
comprendre l'actualité contemporaine et
l'inattendu vous êtes les bienvenus
encore plus aujourd'hui car nous
retrouvons la télévision à mes côtés
tariq al dik amis d'auxerre journaliste
à la rédaction dina bonjour je voulais
de leurs camille vous vous revenez sur
les violences qui ont opposé israéliens
et palestiniens c'est bien les jours
mais avec un message d'espoir mais oui
nathanaël parce que au-delà des
roquettes et des violences des derniers
jours est bien certains juifs et arabes
et c'est en ce moment de faire passer
des messages de paix de vivre ensemble
sur les réseaux sociaux est d'ailleurs
vivre ensemble et bien c'est possible
un village le prouve depuis les années
70 en israël entre tel-aviv et jérusalem
il s'appelle névés shalom auras tu as
salam qui veut dire oasis de paix en
hébreu et en arabe
il regroupe des familles juives
israéliennes musulmane palestinienne et
même catholique et il prouve donc que la
vie ensemble est possible on a retrouvé
une trace de ce village dans les
archives de l'ina on est en 1988 et la
voix ces jeux le reporter charles
enderlin la coexistence n'est donc pas
une utopie mais bien une réalité pour
les seize familles juives et arabes qui
habite névés shalom le village de la
paix sur cette colline à mi chemin entre
tel-aviv et jérusalem
les cours se font dans les deux langues
en hébreu et en arabe
ils apprennent avant tout leur langue à
écrire et à lille
et quand ils connaissent bien leur
langue et comment écrire et lire l'autre
fille date et à l'harmonica
je crois que nous avons réussi à élever
nos enfants dans notre esprit de
coexistence et nous lançons un appel à
tous les juifs et à tous les
palestiniens pour qu ils nous imitent
il n'y a pas d'autre issue au conflit
voilà un appel lancé en 1988 qui résonne
évidemment en 2021
sachez qu'aujourd'hui ce village il
regroupe 120 familles installées ou en
voie d'installation
là vous avez raison souligné que la voix
était celle de charles enderlin
emblématique correspondant de france
télévisions dans cette région du monde à
l'artère hic avec vous on part en voyage
registre sympa en train c'est le retour
de grand retour des trains de nuit ça
reprend avec le premier paris-nice by
night ce jeudi 20 mai d'autres lignes
vont suivre ce pas ce paris-nice sachez
que les prix vont commencer 19 euros
pour l'aller retour
d'ailleurs si on ne sait pas c'est que
c'était pas cher c'est un argument
économique alors d'autres lignes vont
suivre mais en attendant je vais vous
embarquer en 1975 à bord du train de
bill il s'appelle comme ça on va voir ça
tout de suite dans un grand luxe le
temps ne peux pas te paraître
or disent que si elles étaient vous
agréable pour les personnes qui n'ont
plus l'habitude de voyager par le train
qui voyagent souvent un avion très vite
alors maintenant on prend le temps de
vivre on part en vacances on va au
cinéma
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire encore cette
heure ci dans le train 2000 continuer à
boire
allez pullman au bar converser en
écoutant de la musique ou somme de l'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
semblant de france télévisions de
français musulmans qui relance le train
2010 on ne demande que ça mais j'en
doute en tout cas voilà je vous le
disais sacrés arguments économiques et
écologiques et ça c'est déjà pas mal
alors tout cas c'était l'actualité de
cette semaine avec tarik et camille mais
que s'est il passé le 19 mai à travers
le temps regardez le zapping de l'ina ça
s'est passé un 19 m si si bonjour je
regarde la pendule avec vous trois deux
un
il est 20 heures giscard 50,9 mitterrand
49,1 avec 57% des voix en sa faveur le
président sortant assad rohani est
réélue dès le premier tour avec lui
celle elle progressiste et la politique
d'ouverture du pays qui l'emportent
[Musique]
les américains avaient tous une histoire
d'amour avec elle et cette nuit à 22h15
leur coeur s'est brisé lorsque
jacqueline kennedy onassis est morte
dans son appartement de manhattan
les français n'aiment pas gagné j'ai
gagné c'est tout ça suffit les arènes de
lutèce ont connu une fois de plus le
traditionnel pardon de simplice et la
duchesse de bretagne et ses demoiselles
d'honneur qui devait présider ce
festival folklorique auquel participent
et de nombreux groupes
en tout 500 danseurs en costumes
régionaux à rien et meghan markle une
histoire d'amour qui fait rêver c'est
britannique
c'est à londres qu'il suive l'événement
loin de la foule mais au coeur des
jardins royaux de kensington moment
d'émotion lors de l'échangé des
consentements
bonsoir ya demain
[Musique]
il y avait peut-être passé tout ou
partie de la journée après plusieurs
mois de fermeture les terrasses de nos
cafés de nos restaurants peuvent de
nouveau accueillir du public les
terrasses des cafés et des restaurants
camille c'est une tradition bien
française
oui c'est une tradition mais même pour
certains plus que ça c'est je dirais une
extension même de leur domicile six mois
qu'on attendait ça toute la journée on
les a vus ces français revenir sur les
terrasses qui pour l'occasion parfois se
sont agrandies un petit peu étendu le
petit café du matin le rosé au soleil
nathanel alors fondé sa maison le rosé
tout coûte autant de raisons du gars qui
font que ces terrasses nous ont tant
manqué je peux avoir un café l'addition
s'il vous plaît vous auriez une table e
pour 4 en terrasse ils n'ont pas fini de
courir et les garçons de café permet je
demande qu'on nous amène à voir parce
qu'on en soit c'est facile alors à boire
depuis des décennies partout en france
quand le soleil arrive les terrasses
reprennent leur quartier c'était déjà le
cas en 1947
rené faure des terrasses de café le
salon dans la rue la rue d'un vin vers
le salon dans la rue la rue dans un
verre et le spectacle en terrasse peut
commencer parce qu'avant tout on vient
là pour voir et pour se faire voir
allez rendez vous aux terrasses des
cafés
on boit peu d'ailleurs mais on s'agite
beaucoup ne prenez surtout pas que ces
jeunes gens viennent ici pour boire mais
il faut bien payer sa place comme dans
tous les pays
qu'est ce que vous voudrez mademoiselle
cambounet au café à du café cas très
chaud café café sur café - est pas pour
tout le monde pour boit un coup draguer
même pour travailler la terrasse est le
lieu préféré des français
preuve en est avec cette jeune étudiante
en 1962 mademoiselle
vous arrivez à travailler malgré le
bruit dans tout ce monde
oui bien sûr il faut il y a
qu'est-ce qu'on vous prête en ce moment
bien je relève des notes sur jean-paul
ça et depuis toutes ces années le ballet
des terrasses reste le même mais jamais
ensemble
chaque matin c'est le même ballet qui
recommence guéridon chaises parasols et
tabourets valse pour trouver leur place
sur les terrasses et jusque sur les
places de livraison à sa sortie ces
sportifs et ses mythiques les terrasses
française les touristes en sont friands
c'est très français
je sais que c'est un endroit important
où se retrouvaient les intellectuels on
voit les gens on sent les gens vont donc
[Musique]
être au milieu de la vie voilà sûrement
pourquoi on les aime tant nos terrasses
enfin retrouvé ça devrait même être
remboursé par la sécurité sociale
c'est pas une mauvaise idée remboursés
par la sécurité sociale camille au début
du sujet on a vu des garçons de café qui
courait un petit peu dans tous les sens
ça me rappelle vaguement aux arguments
quelque chose c'est une vieille
tradition française née au début du
siècle dernier alors ça a commencé à
paris puis ça s'est propagé un peu à
toute la france voire même à l'étranger
aujourd'hui on peut en voir en chine aux
états unis et donc c'est des centaines
de garçons de café qui court pendant des
kilomètres en essayant de ne pas faire
tomber leurs plateaux s'éliminer ces
éliminatoires évidemment on va on va
leur rendre hommage et donc direction
nîmes en 1963 quand sport et travail se
rencontrent cela peut donner une course
de garçons de café par exemple celle de
nîmes a fait la preuve mais qui en
doutait qu imparfait serveur doit être à
la fois tête des gens des gens bourrés
l'os et une tête froide
prompte à surprendre la commande certes
mais aussi en surveiller le constante
équilibre vint ensuite l'esprit et ce
fut enfin le baiser au vainqueur
l'odeur était so voilà on a dit qu'elle
agit dit et on leur souhaite d'avoir des
jambes véloce et une tête bien froide
tous ses serveurs qui vont pas mal bossé
ces prochains jours
ils sont entraînés pour la revendre
reprises
[Musique]
lundi dernier la journée mondiale contre
l'homophobie a été célébrée un petit peu
partout dans le monde je rappelle que 70
nations considèrent encore
l'homosexualité comme un délit
l'occasion pour sos homophobie de
publier son rapport annuel sur les
discriminations regarder 1815
témoignages d'agressions été relancé en
2020 bonjour lucile joma alors vous êtes
présidente de sos homophobie
est ce que la crise sanitaire a eu un
impact sur les discriminations oui on
cette crise a vraiment eu un impact
important sur les discriminations vécues
par les personnes lgbt
on a pu voir avec cette crise sanitaire
des changements dans nos habitudes avec
le confinement le couvre-feu on a été
amené à changer donc nos habitudes et du
coup ça a entraîné une modification des
violences subies par les personnes lgbt
on a eu beaucoup plus de violence qui se
sont exercés dans les familles et dans
le voisinage est beaucoup moins dans
l'espace public
alors tu arrives vous avez retrouvé des
archives qui illustrent l'évolution des
18 nations à travers le temps il y en a
une qui vous a interpellé qui vous a
même donné une petite idée
c'est un micro-trottoir de 1979 alors on
me pose une question qui est très courte
et très clair c'est qu'est ce que vous
pensez des [ __ ] alors on peut se dire
comme ça que 41 ans après 7h ce serait
compliqué aujourd'hui de poser
exactement la même question se seraient
même compliqué de poser la question où
elle nous l'a fait on l'a fait avec
géraldine cornet lavaud on a essayé on a
tourné tout ça avant les mesures
sanitaires regarde à quoi ça ressemble
est ce que vous pensez des [ __ ]
j'ai pas eu que vous aimez pas pourquoi
j'ai pas
sauf que c'est les
je sais pas j'ai pas du tour du cap
c'est vrai malade il faut tenir à la gym
qu'est ce que vous pensez des [ __ ]
pardon des homosexuels ces initiales ou
c'est un mot vulgaire pour dire guen par
le plus c'est un peu choqué ces termes
que j'emploie pas madame excusez moi
mais comprenez vous les admis que les
maoris j'ai des amis puissants comme ça
il ya soixante dix ans que je suis dans
le quartier de lui et l'a jamais entendu
avec un pic à tes propres filets pour
vous les acceptez vous les comprenez je
les accepte j'ai je les comprends c'est
un peu bizarre comme question oui je les
comprends enfin je comprends à quel
titre en fait d'aimer quelqu'un d'autre
ouais je les comprends vous les acceptez
vous les comprenez ben oui j'en ai dans
ma famille j'ai mon petit cousin donc
voilà comment jugez vous les hommes qui
aiment les hommes
c'est un amour ne croyez pas je crois
pas comment vous jugez les hommes qui
aiment les hommes
moi je porte un jugement je suis pas
dieu donc pour moi non c'est un homme il
fait sa vie comme il veut puis c'est
tout va ce temps c'est une femme
pareille il n'y avait pas de jugement
c'est normal chacun aime qui m
et c'est pas la sexualité c'est de
l'amour donc voilà combien de voir
lucide et omar est ce que ça n'a pas
valeur de sondage c'est sûr mais est ce
que ça veut dire que les français sont
moins homophobe ou est ce que ça veut
dire que c'est une opinion qu'on va
cacher ou on ne va pas assumer face à
une caméra alors déjà on va commencer
depuis le début tout ce qui fait acte
d'homophobie au fait de rejeter les
homosexuels c'est un c'est pas une
opinion c'est vraiment un délit est puni
par la loi
donc ça et après on voit cette mentalité
qui évolue mais après en 1979 faut bien
se remettre dans le contexte que
l'homosexualité était toujours considéré
comme une maladie mentale que et elles
étaient également condamnés en france
encore donc voilà on est vraiment dans
un contexte différent avec l'évolution
des droits
on a vraiment une évolution des
mentalités ça vous rassure je parle pas
de ce qu'on a entendu en 1979 on oublie
mais de ce que vous avez entendu
aujourd'hui ces gens choqués simplement
parce que on leur pose la question c'est
sur la bonne voie oui on la sait ce
qu'on entend c'est vraiment sur la bonne
voie on voit que les gens acceptent
beaucoup plus l'homosexualité
bien sûr on n'entend parler que du terme
pd1 donc un terme qui est vraiment là
pour rabaisser donc les homosexuels
c'est vraiment un
une insulte qui a pour but de rabaisser
les homosexuels à une condition de femme
parce que bien sûr les femmes dans la
société sont considérés comme inférieurs
aux sommes donc donc voilà c'est des
éléments qui montre quand même une
évolution mais il ya encore du travail
le sujet mais en 1975 24% des français
considèrent que l'homosexualité est une
manière de vivre sa sexualité comme une
autre en misant en 2020 ils sont 85%
qu'est ce qui s'est passé
et bien des gens premiers éléments c'est
toutes les réformes qui a pu la voir
dans la société et donc le fait d'avoir
une égalité qui fait actuellement n'a
pas encore une égalité de droit on le
voit avec la pma mais en attendant on se
rapproche de quelque chose qui est qui
se rapproche d'une égalité entre tous
les individus et donc dès qu'on aura une
égalité de droit ça voudra dire qu'on
est égaux est vraiment qu'il ya pu cette
notion on est des êtres inférieurs
vous voulez les temps forts c'est trente
quarante dernières années
justement pour pour arriver à ce
changement des mentalités et ce qui en a
qui si vous deviez les classer par
exemple c'est quoi le le pacs par
exemple le mariage le premier ça a été
vraiment la dépénalisation de
l'homosexualité en 1982 après le pacs
bien sûr il ya également eu les
premières lois de lutte contre les
discriminations et puis bah bien sûr le
mariage pour tous
mais qui a ses proches qui étaient dans
2012 donc du coup voilà ça ça permet de
montrer vraiment une d'amener vers une
véritable égalité des droits
inversement cette discrimination s'est
développé ces axes planté notamment à
cause d'internet
alors on pourrait pas forcément dire
qu'elle s'est accentuée c'est juste que
l est beaucoup plus visible les gens
dénoncent plus aux siens et après bien
sûr il ya internet qui explose c'est
vraiment un espace où les gens se
parlent sans filtre sans même se rendre
compte de la portée de leur geste
puisque bien sûr et c'est un derrière un
écran plus grand
exactement il y en a qui est qui qui
parle également sous pseudo donc voilà
ça ça a plus accès à distance entre la
victime ce bien sûr c'est une victime
qu'il ya de l'autre côté et la personne
qui va être l'agresseur ou l'agresseuse
alors un des volets de votre étude c'est
le sait bien entendu la discrimination
sur le lieu professionnel
les agressions dans le monde
professionnel tariqa sujets oubliés nous
montrer une archive oui pas si j'avais
une archive à vous montrer ce serait
super mais non il y en a tellement j'en
ai choisi trois quand même parce que le
temps nous manque un alors il ya des
témoignages d'homosexuels et de
transgenre et nous parle de peur de
rejet et de violence dans le milieu dans
lequel vous vivez
je suppose qu'on peut pas dire ces
choses là bas c'est pas tellement
comment en sommes nous si vous lisiez
qu'est ce qui arriverait les insultes
montra un peu du devoir 21 bd vous même
qu'est qui vous vous êtes prise de
télévision et maintenant je suis un peu
sur la touche mais en fait j'ai paris
vous disais à la fin d'une journée de
travail va bouffer du sperme ailleurs
reculé au mode merde sale [ __ ] vous vous
dites
vous avez vous avez un réel souci il n'y
a pas un jeu peut pas travailler avec
des gens qui sont capables de m'écrire
ce genre dasani t voilà donc ces trois
archives qu'on a vu si je les ai choisi
c'est parce qu'elle montre plusieurs
points qui représente un peu l'ensemble
des archives que j'ai pu consulter
en outre qu'on dispose dont on dispose à
li na la première c'est que en majorité
enfin les deux sur les trois ce sont des
personnes qui parlent à visage découvert
et je trouve que c'est assez important
de le souligner le deuxième c'est que on
a vu des reportages de différentes
décennies on voit aussi que non
seulement on en parle à la télé mais en
plus c'est un phénomène qui perdure il
ya toujours des démos des témoignages
depuis les années 60 est encore
aujourd'hui
et le troisième c'est que ce sont
beaucoup d'hommes qui prennent la parole
ou bien du côté des personnes
transgenres ça va être des homme devenu
femme en tout cas des femmes transgenres
qu'on va malheureusement percevoir comme
et c'est à ce sujet là que je voulais
vous interpellez lucie germain
ça en dit long aussi sur
l'invisibilisation des femmes
ah oui alors là les archives que vous
avez montré en sont un exemple les
femmes déjà dans notre société sont
beaucoup plus en visibilité dans les
années 70 n'en parlons même pas encore
aujourd'hui on çà progresse mais il ya
encore des choses à faire et du coup
pour les femmes qui vont être homosexuel
c'est vraiment une double discrimination
elles vont être complètement invisible
is et dans la société
ça c'est quelque chose qu'il faut bien
prendre en compte et les femmes qui sont
bisexuels également est ce que le
télétravail qui qui s'est développé un
accent très fortement cette année une
année particulière est-ce que vous avez
constaté justement avec ce télé de
travail une baisse des discriminations
homophobes sur l'espace professionnel
alors qu'arnaud on n'a pas réellement
observées de diminution de ces
discriminations faut pas oublier que ces
discriminations bas comme dans l'espace
familial ou le voisinage on va croiser
ses collègues régulièrement et en
télétravail on va toujours être en
contact on va toujours subir des petites
attaques des petites piques des et du
harcèlement puisque bien sûr ce sont des
personnes que l'on connaît
et donc ils vont
tout le temps renchérir faut pas oublier
non plus que c'est un climat qui secret
en général c'est pas juste une personne
qui va avoir des actes homophobes direct
transphobes c'est vraiment un groupe
parfois même qui n'est pas en campagne
avoir de sanction et c'est presque
accepter de la part des deux organes de
l'employeur à une obligation de
protection vis-à-vis exactement
normalement ce devrait ça devrait être
des actes qui sont punis qui sont
sanctionnés par par les supérieurs
hiérarchiques
alors dans l'actualité il ya aussi logo
phobie dans le monde du football avec le
livre d'un ancien membre du centre de
formation du toulouse football club tfc
wissem ben belgacem hauteur de adieu ma
honte chez fayard un sujet dont on parle
peu tarie qu'un c'est rare les
footballeur
les footballeurs professionnels qui
témoigne non non on en parle c'est très
très peu c'est juste complètement
exceptionnel vous pouvez le dire j'ai
regardé toutes les archives j'en ai pas
vus j'ai regardé aussi tout simplement
est ce que je connais est ce que mes
amis connaissent en le joueurs
professionnels homosexuels non cela dit
j'ai trouvé un reportage une archive de
2005 de stade 2 qui consacre un
reportage à l'homosexualité dans le foot
on y voit un club amateur gay qui
s'appelle le paris football gay on y
voit aussi certains joueurs
professionnels qui ont des paroles de
tolérance envers les homosexuels
mais aucun joueur professionnel gay
vraiment là à ce niveau là ça coince
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont tabou aussi chez
les pros on a contacté une dizaine de
footballeurs gays jouant tous ayant joué
au plus haut niveau mais aucun d'entre
eux n'a voulu parler à la télé en
revanche ils ont expliqué à ce
sociologue
les raisons de cette discrétion qu'on
pourrait dire tout d'abord que ils ont
une certaine peur
être reconnus comme des homosexuels et
que finalement s'ils sont improductifs
sur le terrain ils vont être traité de
[ __ ] ou ça sera la faute de tous les
homosexuels de france et navarre une
autre raison tient aux sponsors eux
mêmes c'est à dire que certains sponsors
n'hésitent pas à demander à leurs
athlètes de s'afficher et de donner le
change avec des femmes de manière à
cacher leur homosexualité
donc ça c'était il ya 15 ans mais ça n'a
pas du tout bougé on entend qu'il ya un
problème d'image qu'il ya un problème
économique même est ce que ça ferait pas
un peu de bien tout simplement d'avoir
ces paroles là qui surgissent parce
qu'on sait qu'il y en a des joueurs
professionnels homosexuels
mais que ce soit dans le foot wire des
personnes de notoriété exactement c'est
depuis quinze ans ça n'a pas changé il
ya toujours pas de footballeurs qui qui
sont out dans le sport en tout cas en
france
ça a évolué un peu plus vite pour les
femmes il ya la gardienne de foot
pauline perreault qui a fait son coming
out l'année dernière donc ça fait du
bien de voir des images de personnalités
qui qui ceux qui parlent d'eux mêmes
entièrement en fait sans se cacher donc
ça voilà c'est vraiment des rôles de
modèle et il faut pas oublier quand même
que pour que les gens soient out pour
que les gens des voix lors de leur
identité ou alors leur orientation
sexuelle il faut que le climat soit
serein faut qu'il se sent bien faut
qu'ils aient de la bienveillance et
c'est pas actuellement le cas dans le
sport donc voilà ce qui est quand même
inquiétant si vous me permettez c'est
que il y a des des footballeurs
professionnels qui témoigne de manière
anonyme et explique surtout pourquoi est
ce qu il ne témoigne pas à visage
découvert pourquoi est-ce qu'ils vont
pas leur coming out
ils ont peur bien entendu des réactions
de leurs potes dans les vestiaires mais
aussi de l'impact que cela pourrait
avoir des retombées financières quoi des
sponsors les médias et quelques pas de
la responsabilité
elle est générale elle les fédérations
ont leur rôle dedans dans ce système qui
qui qui complètement cachent les
personnes qui sont homosexuels c'est
vraiment un rôle donc là il faut
vraiment qu'il ya des choses qui se
mettent en place pour créer un climat un
climat serein et que les personnes après
puissent faire leur coming out
au moins on le sait un câlin qui ont
déjà fait leur coming out auprès de
leurs collègues mais publiquement non et
après il faut aussi garder en tête que
il est important pour les jeunes et les
moins jeunes d'ailleurs d'avoir de
véritables représentation de personnes
qui vivent leur homosexualité de manière
ordinaire dans la vie de tous les jours
et montrer qu'on peut aussi réussir sa
vie qu on peut faire plein de choses et
ça c'est super important pour les jeunes
et pour les moins jeunes aussi
voilà les explications important de
lucile joma président de sos homophobie
merci à vous d'être avec nous avant de
refermer cette inattendue notre
traditionnel pépite cette semaine c'est
une archive de 1983 les charlots chante
l'apéro bkx une parodie de l'émission
gym tonic de véronique et davina bien
sûr
la paire vie simard ouest de l'île
robin
[Musique]
voilà un petit clin d'oeil bien sûr à
toutes celles et ceux qui ont pu
profiter aujourd'hui de la réouverture
des terrasses pour prendre un petit
apéro avec modération bien sûr on se
retrouve mercredi prochain 22 heures sur
le canal 27 août la semaine sur les
réseaux sociaux france info lina mission
préparer avec les documentalistes anne
delavaux laurence mattioli merci à elle
et merci à vous d'être fidèle toutes les
semaines à l'inattendu
[Musique]